[Music]
what's up
everyone welcome to culture binge the
wisecrack podcast where we
dig around and explore what's going on
in the zeitgeist so we can talk about it
with you
our friends and family uh i am michael
and i'm joined by
wisecrack writer which is such a it
feels like not enough because he's so
much more than that alec alec how you
doing
i'm i'm well thanks for making me feel
weird
yeah i like making you feel weird by
complimenting you it's always good when
you could be nice to someone and also
make them feel bad
um yeah and here with wisecrack
researcher sergey sevi how are you
hi i'm well how are you good everyone's
well
so that's great to hear um we're excited
to be back we haven't been with you for
a little bit we haven't been live with
you so we're excited
we've got a lot to talk about today
we're going to talk about sports inside
of bubbles
we're going to talk about why privacy is
over and you need to deal with it
and then we'll talk a little bit about
your parents favorite app tick tock
um but first i want to let everyone know
we're gonna try something new today
and we want to respond to some questions
from the chat so if you're on youtube
right now if you're watching this
um ask questions it could be about a
topic
ideally that uh it could be about alex
personal life it could be about
serbia's taste and carbonated beverages
um
it could be about my fractured
relationship with my mother whatever you
want to know
and we will i'm just kidding i love you
ma and we will talk about that
in between topics so uh we'll keep an
eye on the chat please feel free to
participate
i already see questions coming and i
love you all for that but let's get
going
you know what got to do first slaps and
chaps serbia let's start
it off what is slapping what is chapping
uh
so what slaps is a
new documentary on netflix called
athlete a
it's about the usa gymnastics team
and how they covered up years of abuse
it was really well done and i really
enjoyed watching it
uh what chaps is
really just i've been feeling kind of
down the last few weeks i think maybe
i'm
staying at home and starting to get to
me weather is beautiful
so i'm hitting that wall now where i
want to get out and go around but i'm
not going to
that's very real that's very very real
um alec i'm going to cheat i think
uh i've got two slaps uh first is
crossword puzzles i'm really
leaning into being an 80 year old man uh
or a woman
just either or uh puzzles and crosswords
are a significant portion of my life and
also and i brought this up to you
michael uh we talked about soggy take
out food and
a chinese food place i had delivered
poked holes
in all the fried stuff so it didn't get
soggy please
everyone take out everywhere do this
it's amazing uh
as far as chaps uh also
feeling that i need to stay the [ __ ]
home but god i just wish i could go to
the gym but also not really i don't want
to kill anyone
uh it's not because i'm a big small man
or anything like that yes
i'm just a feeble chronically impaired
jewish man
uh who needs to to work out his back is
all i'm saying
wow um the back thing is real relatable
stuff
uh and i just think that chinese
restaurant that's doing the
air hole thing is genius we all know
that the reason you should never
in general order fried foods or crispy
foods for delivery is because moisture
builds up in the container
and the crispiness turns to sogginess
this is why you eat french fries
in the bag as you're leaving the place
but this is a great innovation and it's
something that
if spacex is going to spend so much time
flying rockets to mars someone needs to
spend time figuring out how we can get
crispy foods
taken to our homes um my slaps and chaps
pretty quick one
i thought that a movie that came out
this weekend slapped and that's palm
springs on
hulu it's movie starring andy samberg
christina miliotti it's a
kind of a comedy kind of a uh science
fiction movie it deals with the
questions of time loops
i shouldn't have even said that much if
you know nothing about it go watch the
trailer i saw the trailer
oh yeah it's not sure which never mind
um but it's good and i think we live in
an
era where you all might have noticed
that like good comedies don't
really get made anymore so um it's great
just to see a good comedy movie getting
made
that isn't really dumb it's not a
perfect movie but it's the first movie
that's come
out during uh the pandemic that i
thought which is really good so watch
that if you have a hulu account and if
you don't
um steal a friend's account uh chaps
this is very simple
um in california where two of us live i
won't say which two
um you can no longer easily get
coronavirus testing and
that's kind of sucks a nice thing that
we've had here is that you've been able
to get testing pretty easily you know
about three weeks ago i was able to
drive up to dodger stadium
um get a test in 40 minutes get my
results in about 20 hours
now that's completely changed uh and
it's it's it's a bummer i
i won't get too much into it why okay
never mind
no no you can no do it it's fine no uh
why is it
because i think there's been
this is a separate topic but anyway
it seems like some people are like oh if
i get the test i can do
literally whatever i want which is not
true and yeah it's in response to like a
sort of like i don't want to say over
testing i don't mean that in the sort of
like
trumpian sense well the the logic behind
it is good in that
new york times had an article on it
today about testing in california
they got at this idea that they want to
prioritize frontline workers
um lower wage workers who are the ones
most likely to get it which is a good
thing we need to take care of those
people
so that's a good thing on the flip side
we know that one of the things if we
look internationally
that's helped other countries uh get
back to some semblance of decent if not
normal
as is a is mass public access to texting
so it is a little dis
discouraging at this point in the game
to see testing get limited in california
rather than ramped up
i mean we will say before we get into it
as well uh things to do to buy 1985 for
throwing some coin our way
and giving us some recommendations as
well so we appreciate that
um let's just get right into it anything
else anyone
feel like they need to say is a
preferatory remark before we dive into
our exploration of the culture
no no go for it okay great um so i'll
start
for our first topic we're gonna talk
about sports bubbles and in particular
the nba bubble this is a big day for me
as i remember one of the first
times i got involved at all with
anything wisecrack related
i wrote some ideas for videos down that
i think jared maybe alec looked at and i
had one
that had to do with sports and i got
this response that said
no um so i'm getting to talk about
sports
and uh on a wisecrack property so this
feels subversive and great
um and i'm not the biggest sports guy
but i do like the nba
uh but so here's what's happening all
the sports stopped
um in march and if anything for me
sports are very tied into the
coronavirus pandemic
because it was on i think wednesday
march 13th i might get the date a little
bit wrong
that um the nba suddenly canceled games
and they cancelled games as games were
starting
because cases started happening amongst
players so there was one instance where
in oklahoma city
they were about to start a game and the
announcer said tonight's game has been
canceled
you're not in danger but please leave
the arena it's very terrifying because
when someone says you're not in danger
you know you're about to die
um sure but so so for me like
that was the moment where i felt like oh
[ __ ] this is real this is a
multi-billion dollar industry if they're
shutting down
serious stuff is happening and ever
since that happened the mba has been
talking about
restarting in a bubble format which
means
one location everyone contained people
getting tested every day
anyone coming from the outside
quarantining so they can finish the
season
um so this is what the nba is doing they
were between vegas and disney world
uh they said vegas was too risky because
people would want to sneak out and party
so they are at disney world in orlando
um
sorry i knew they were doing they're
dude they're doing it indeed why not
like in the middle of oklahoma
because they need a location that has
nice hotels and big sports facilities
and disney in orlando has a thing called
the wide world of sports complex
which is a massive um sports with courts
gyms all that sort of stuff so it was a
place that would give them access to
both lodging and athletic facilities
and the best part about it is the day
that everyone got there
was the day that florida had the highest
amount of covet cases
that we've yet had so that's fun that
that's how it started but so they're
basically locked down in disney i guess
it's like a nine-year-old's dream
um they're playing all the games there
now 22 teams with staffs went the teams
get 17 players on their roster but then
you had coaching coaching staffs
trainers so you have a lot of people um
journalists got to go as well
so you have a bunch of journalists that
are there but
so everyone got there about a week ago
games start on july 30th
and the season concludes on october 13th
so you're talking about
three months of players coaches
media members locked into disney to try
to finish the nba season now
since this has happened many people have
said this is a bad idea for a lot of
reasons
um and i'm sure many of these we can
just assume in terms of if one or two
people
do contract covid that's going to spread
through this place like wildfire the
other question is is it worth starting
professional sports right now with
everything else we have going on
another kind of moral issue we can get
into this is testing
um the same testing company that's
processing all the mba tests in orlando
was was delayed in processing uh test
results for high-risk patients in
orlando
so you have this question too like are
you going to be bummed when grandma dies
so a bunch of healthy 22 year olds can
get cova test twice a day
um i'll tell you a few more facts about
it we can talk about it
but to to sort of be safe everyone has
to quarantine for 10 days when we get
there so
a journalist for example if you show up
you are in your hotel room for 10 days
you get to leave once a day to get a
covet test and you're back in your room
all your food's delivered to you
you can't go on walks you can't exercise
all that sort of stuff
two players have already broke
quarantine one did it because
and i have to respect this he didn't
like the food so we did a little
postmates action
had to walk across the official
quarantine line to pick up his postmates
um but it was the most expensive
postmates ever because now he has to
quarantine for 10 entire days
another player yeah
another player left his room during a
mandatory 48-hour period where he didn't
get results so he's in for 10 days now
two of the league's biggest stars
russell westbrook and james harden
um both have tested positive for covid
so they can't even go to orlando yet
um and there's also a snitch hotline so
the nba has set up a hotline where
players can call and tattle
on anyone who who breaks quarantine
so it's i don't know as a basketball fan
i will gladly watch basketball on tv
because it's something to do
as a person who cares about this sort of
stuff
um it seems like a bad idea what do you
what do you sports fans think
uh i i love no i don't care about sports
uh
but obviously it's form of entertainment
i
when i first heard about it i it seemed
because i know they're doing a similar
thing with baseball
it seemed like possibly not the worst
idea but i think the more information i
get it becomes
less and less of a good idea because you
know if you've got
you know let's just say theoretically
like 10 people kind of like in close
quarters with each other but they're
staying safe they're
quarantined from the outside world like
yeah fine whatever but then you're like
throwing in journalists and staff and
all these things and also just like
young rich people who don't want to like
listen to anybody else and they're in
the middle of disney world and
yeah it seems you know maybe even the
players will be fine but will the people
working around them and also i think
there's a lot of stuff like um
we're getting more and more information
about uh i think there's this
misconceived notion that like let's say
the covet mortality rate's one percent
and maybe even lower for young people
um that does not include the high
percentage of cases that
end in hospitalization that lead them
like neurological problems
this is i i don't like severe ones this
is not a severe one but i have
two friends who got it in march who are
young and healthy and they still can't
taste things correctly
now obviously not onion's tasting weird
is fine whatever
um but there's other problems we're
unsure of like sort of the long-term
health effects of it like will you be
more susceptible to things like heart
attacks or
strokes or anything like that and also
just like i know
uh people who get put on ventilators
even when they're taken off
have like a really sort of long-term
like lung and throat problems as a
result of it um
i think i mentioned before there's a guy
he's a marathon runner he's a legal
writer david lat who wrote about his
experience being hospitalized with kovid
i mean the dude runs marathons but he
also uses inhaler and he kind of thought
he was like good to go
not that he was being risky or dangerous
and so i just wonder like
you know are we gonna find out yeah i
don't know like
are we they're not kids obviously in the
nba but like are we sacrificing these
young people or the people that work
around them um
should we maybe just put all of our like
effort time and energy into like a sport
that's maybe a little bit safer than
basketball like maybe we should all just
watch tennis
i also think tennis is boring but like
probably safer
yeah i think this is so dumb like is
this
like do we really need to spend this
much money and time
to figure out the logistics of how we're
going to get basketball in the air
i appreciate that it's a form of
entertainment i know there's nothing to
do right now i know people have
jobs that are connected to the nba
like the concession stand workers or the
camera operators or the journalists or
whatever
that this just feels so unsafe and what
what
measures are put in place to ensure that
people
don't break quarantine or don't switch
line
the snitch line but are they tracking
them like do we have any software on
their cell phones to ensure that they're
staying where they're supposed to be
right at one point they were and i don't
know if this is still the case uh maybe
someone in the chat knows you can let us
know
but they were going to wear these like
bracelets that were going to track
them and their health stats and were
supposedly
going to be able to predict if they were
getting covet or something
which i don't know i don't think that's
still happening but at one point that
was going to
it's weird because i am sort of like oh
that's a good idea it's also an episode
of black mirror i mean it's not
exactly but uh yeah do the
do the players like it have there been
any players that are like i'm not doing
this in the nba or otherwise
so oh yeah so a lot of players have
opted out now some players have opted
out because they or their families have
health
health issues um one i know a couple
players opted out at least one
because his wife was expecting a child
and he didn't want to miss the birth of
his first child because once you're in
you're in and if you're good so like if
you were on a team like the clippers or
the lakers or the bucks
you're gonna be there for three months
at least completely separated
from your family there was talk about
letting family in at one point but i
don't know
where that's going so i don't know it's
like a pretty serious commitment
and then we know that psychologically
it's going to be weird and some players
have complained about the hotel rooms
although a player rajon rondo
who's on the lakers posted some clips
comparing his hotel room to the motel 6
and the internet quickly called him out
because it was quite a nice hotel room
that for most of us
would be a nice time and some players
complained about the food but for the
first week
their meals are brought to them by like
team doctors starting next week they're
able to order food from restaurants
including morton's steakhouse
so they have like a good list they can
order from and then they even have stuff
like they have dj nights where djs are
coming they're gonna show
um i think marvel has given them access
to films early so they're gonna watch
um oh my gosh what's what's the scarlett
johansson one coming out
black little sorry yeah my brain just is
farted um yeah so they're gonna see
black
widow first before all of us um
but to get to maybe something serbia
said i do think it is kind of dumb
i feel like the reason is just it's just
money the owners don't want to lose
money
um the people that own teams make a lot
of money off tv contracts and games
i don't know i just think they wanted to
make sure that their money didn't get
messed with and i do think
for some of the players it's a mix of
wanting to get paid
which is real like if they don't play
they don't get paid
um and you know the pride of wanting to
finish the season and become champions
yeah that makes i mean this is a lame
comparison but i know the
the collegiate debate uh season was cut
short and so a lot of
uh a lot of kids who were very eager to
compete nationally and you know possibly
win the trophy and all that
they just didn't have a chance to do
that and it sucks and you know i imagine
if you're putting
everything into trying to get a a
basketball
championship it is probably
bad very bad uh yeah can we just invent
another sport where like
everyone's in a bubble and uh i don't
know
or like this is gonna sound so dumb
because i'm not a sports
can't we just like just all decide that
we're gonna air like the 1968 season
and then like we're gonna like nobody
remembers it i mean i'm sure some people
do
but yeah you know just just relive it
like it never happened everyone no one
will get spoilers it'll be fun
well so professional baseball is
starting back up as well i think that
starts up on the 30th as well
but what i guess with baseball it's
different because you're so far away
you're basically just stan i mean think
about this like we know that with kovid
you want to be outside um baseball's
outside
you want to keep six feet and baseball
you're keeping much more than six feet
unless you're in the batter's box
so in a sense baseball is a pretty safe
sport because you're standing outside
far away from people
the bummer is the travel because they're
not doing a bubble they're playing
other teams and traveling to other
cities
so um and someone did point out in the
chat how weird it's going to be to have
these games without fans and that's
another huge thing these players who are
used to playing for like
between 15 and 30 000 people who are
screaming
are going to play in gyms and disney
that nobody is in
that's got to be surreal that sounds
awesome someone in the comments is uh
saying can't you argue that sport's a
necessity for the country's mental
health and
i don't want to say sports explicitly
but yeah like i get it like
if uh you know certainly for asking
people to stay inside all the time
books puzzles youtube videos this
podcast
we're the real front no i'm just kidding
we're not the front line but it's
important
oh boy i think how distracting i think
it's important but i don't think that
the
benefit that will derive from having
sports
outweighs the risk that we
are about to see like if somebody
breaks the quarantine or this lockdown
situation
and kovid spreads through this entire
nba compound that's like another like
say
5 000 cases that we can see and
that'll put an additional stress on the
health care system so
i do think that it is important but i i
don't think that
i think that we need to we need to like
risk we need to
weigh the risks like what what's worse
like there are other things that you can
do
to alleviate any mental health
i feel like i feel like is it do you do
we want to die
or do we want to just play a puzzle like
that's how i think about things i'm
going to go for the crossword puzzle
i'd rather do a cross hustle
i will die for the nba i'll give my life
for the mba i will bleed
my blood for a league owned by
billionaires no i get what you're saying
um
and i do think not to be silly i i think
there's a very high chance that this
they end up having to cancel it um
that this all falls apart so um just a
reminder too if you're in the chat we
will answer a question we're about to
i'm hinting you off that we're probably
gonna wrap this topic up soon so if you
have anything let us know
um any final thoughts on this will
either of you out of just like
curiosity or boredom watch an nba game
i would be interested in seeing how it
is in a quiet stadium
but i'm sure after like 10 minutes so
i'll get myself
okay alec any chance that you will watch
a
well your your brooklyn nets your
hometown team are getting to play in it
uh in a sort of like last spot trying to
make the playoffs
they're pretty bad though um will you
watch your brooklyn nets
no okay um so it'll just be me
and i'm fine with that um so and i just
i think you're about to point out what i
was about to point out so go ahead alex
oh well i was going to say before we
move on i want to thank dem for donating
some money in the live chat
and also again due to bites who'd pay
top dollar to see serbia on netflix's
the floor is lava so i don't know how
you get on that show serbia but you need
to do it
oh the floor is lava it's like one of
those obstacle course uh shows kind of
i've seen the trailers it kind of seems
like american ninja warrior but the four
is lava like that game you play as a kid
oh yeah oh i would be horrible at that
game
i have really bad balance i'm going to
start a gofundme to get
i don't know how we're going to do we're
going to pay netflix to put serbia on
the show i will say this before we move
on alex sprout of american ninja warrior
that actually is my favorite american
sport it's the only true american sport
oh yeah they could bring that back
because it's one person on a course so
that honestly like
i i haven't heard anything i'm gonna
look this up later i don't know why
they haven't brought that back because
one person at a time but you know
i think this has been this has been a
wisecrack podcast talking about sports
we thank you for sticking around with us
this will happen again sometime in 2023.
um now do we have any questions before
we
move on or just speculation about which
reality show we want to see serbia on
uh so here's a
question from kobe what do you think
about the ufc still putting on fights
despite fighters catching the corona and
if it's still a good idea
that's [ __ ] dumb i think it's a i
just think it's a bad idea because it's
a sport where
you are necessarily breathing spitting
and bleeding
close contact on another person yeah
it's a very
moisture filled like you punch someone
in the face they're just spewing a lot
of
germs at you and you know gotta respect
it but
it seems like a dumb idea uh yeah the
the next one is from oh did i just lose
it
uh from darien uh who says the larger
question is how do we handle all the
people who have entire careers in this
do they start trying to pivot or do we
tell them it's okay i think
darien's referring to people who
probably work in the nba and stuff
yeah well that's hard too because think
about how many people lost jobs who just
like work for teams
or at arenas and stuff like that um i
don't know what the answer is i mean i
universes basic income well i was gonna
say that but i didn't
i didn't want to get political yeah
let's just give people money um
i love it i think that's hard because
if you have a role that's like a camera
operator or like a sound
engineer or something like that where
you have
you're highly skilled but there are no
jobs
for you because all of those roles are
shut down right now if you wanted to
move into films or something like that
but something there it's like i think
it's easy if you have
um specific functions like in marketing
or business development where you have
transferable skills and you can pivot to
another industry
so i think it's i think it's challenging
i don't think there's a right answer
yeah we should yeah so we should keep it
moving i will say and i shouldn't do
this it's been implied in the chat that
people don't enjoy sports i enjoy sports
very much i've been in many sporting
games
um so you don't know me okay so let's
keep going our next topic i'm kidding i
love that everyone's in the chat hanging
out i just gotta let facts be faxed
serbia tell us why privacy is over
and we should just settle in with the
fact that everyone is watching us all
the time forever
sure so i have been thinking a lot about
how videos have been going viral and
we've seen in recent weeks
many videos of people behaving badly
for example someone in central park
threatening a bird watcher
someone else having a meltdown in a
costco
and in many ways we feel like
like we're serving justice like we put
this person on blast we've
publicly showcased someone's misdeeds
and
it feels right and just to put someone
in a public forum for everyone to see
but i also wonder if we're going too far
because is this the end of privacy
and minding our own business so i
started to think about this more because
a couple weeks ago
there was a video of a woman who was
trying to park her car
at a gas station and the woman tried a
few times
to to park next to the gas pump but
she was parking on the opposite side of
where
her gas nozzle is i think we have a
video right
we do yeah and so we can play a few um
the gas tanks on the other side of the
vehicle the gas stakes on the other side
and she already did this once
she just drove okay
so she knows that now i well this is the
so she this is the second time she's
done this so
she she should now drive to the so that
it's on the driver's side the tank
is on the driver's side the same side as
her right yes
but she pulled a circle last time no way
is she gonna do it again now she's gonna
back into the right
yeah no she hadn't if she would've no
she does not know which side the tank is
on or does she think she no she knows
she has to know she just saw that it's
not on the passenger side
okay so she's pulled up again on the
wrong side hang on
oh okay so there you go
we we have an idea of of what occurred
and many people found this video amusing
but there was
one thread on twitter that wonderfully
articulates how i feel about the
situation so i'm going to read it
um it's charlotte climber cm climber on
twitter
and she wrote a series of insightful
comments and
here's a condensed version of her
thoughts so she says
i'm not trying to shame anyone here or
say you're a bad person
or some other nonsense for sharing the
video or laughing at it
but let's back up for a second and
consider some things this woman wasn't
bothering or hurting
anyone she was minding her own business
she happened to be super confused on how
to park near the gas pump
something most of us have done once or
twice but it literally did not affect
anyone else other than her it's kind of
disturbing to me that this woman or
anyone
could be filmed going about their daily
lives unaware that they're being filmed
by strangers
never consenting to it being shared
online and by the time they get home
they find out they've gone viral it's
deeply concerning to me that we're
increasingly seeing a common respect for
basic consideration of privacy be eroded
away
because we're all carrying cell phones
that are technologically capable of
recording and editing short videos
because it's not just a video it's the
comfort we should all
expect to be able to navigate the public
square
without feeling like our every movement
is vulnerable to recording by strangers
input online
it's creepy and dangerous it makes
people feel unsafe
i don't know exactly where the line
should be drawn on expectations of
privacy in a world of smartphones
and i'm certainly no expert on privacy
but i feel like being graceful and
considerate of others is a good place to
start
i know this will come across as scolding
and it's not intended to
we're all human we all laugh at random
things we all make ridiculous mistakes
or just leave our brain at home
sometimes
but we are also all entitled to consent
and a baseline of dignity and respect
and her comments resonate strongly with
me um not
only because i have also done weird
things at gas stations
but also because i have been feeling
increasingly uncomfortable
when making mistakes in public and
there doesn't seem to be any sort of
forgiveness for
harmless mistakes or errors and it seems
like
a singular moment in time is preserved
for
everyone to see and we we don't have
privacy anymore
so what do you think is privacy being
eroded or
is this just the new the new norm
that we need to get used to i will say
that i completely
i saw the same thread on twitter and my
response was
a reaction was the complete opposite of
yours um
i i don't know i was obviously just it
just sounds like kind of
i found it kind of virtue signaling and
a little too precious
and while i get the i think there's a
difference between like privacy
and and i think someone in the chat
pointed this out so i'm just letting you
know i'm giving you credit where
credit's due someone pointed out that
woman was probably on acid
if you take acid and drive to the gas
station that's on you like
that's not i i don't know how do i think
she was on acid
i will say if i i could see that that
behavior would line up with being on a
hallucinogenic also never driving but
also
yeah but no i just i don't i just
hesitate to think that like
we live in a world and also too like the
public you go in a public space you're
in a public space people see you
they might film you i understand the
line between like ruining someone's life
but i don't know we could we could
barely see this person
they were acting kind of foolish i'm
probably just a bad person but that's
that's my gut reaction to that dude
serbia if they're i think the one
specific issue is that their license
plate wasn't blurred out
if it blurt out their face and license
plate would this video be a okay to
laugh at
um i would have
less of a concern about it i think i
would be like yeah whatever
like it's anonymous as anonymous as
anonymous as it could be
yeah she besides the license like she
doesn't seem to
i i agree with you i
think i'm not a monster like michael but
uh
i i mostly agree with you but i think
like it's interesting because this is
certainly like a harmless
dumb thing and i don't think anyone's
life has been ruined by
like doing anything harmless and dumb uh
actually that's not true
uh there's that john ronson book so
you've been publicly shamed and i think
one of the examples
in there is this girl who was like going
around
kind of like the first world anarchist
thing like the sign says don't touch i'm
gonna take a picture of touching it
and then i think she went to uh
arlington cemetery and was like be
respectful so she's like what's the most
and she like posed in front like of the
the cemetery like flipping things off or
whatever and her life
was ruined for a long time and you know
you could say that was in very poor
taste but certainly different than like
you know being a person destroying a
mcdonald's for
like being asked to wear a mask or
something like that um
and so i don't know i think there's two
things like i
cert like in one sense it used to be
uh we were being surveilled in ways that
were
sort of top down uh maybe a little less
so in america but certainly like in the
uk
like with cctv everywhere um you know
cameras like that
but now it's sort of like it's not just
the government who has the cameras like
everyone does and like
but to michael's point there is like a
you're in the public sphere there is no
sort of expectation of privacy but then
there's the whole problem of like
being sort of made immortal in your
shittiness i know like
the eu has laws about the right to be
forgotten
which is really tricky because on one
hand
if you're this person and you don't want
your career to be ruined by
some dumb thing you did at a gas station
or some like
ill-thought-out prank you made in a
cemetery uh
you know you could press for like those
results to not be
like listed under google at the same
time lots of very powerful people have
used them to cover up their their very
public shittiness
um and so i think it's really tricky and
also
you know you mentioned like the guy
freaking out in costco feeling
like i feel threatened or the woman who
called the cops on the birders which uh
i mean i'll use the murder example like
she could have gotten a dude killed
and i think another part of this is that
i feel like as weird and
tricky and complicated and possibly
problematic like some of the
the shame culture happens is like i
think it's a result of the feeling that
there is no other outlet of justice um
right like
if we felt that the central park karen
uh would have just in the normal like
operation of things gotten charged with
like following a false police report
uh and like something you know sort of
uh the punishment fits the crime i don't
think
that would exist similarly like if you
look at something like
me too like a lot of the the like a lot
of that stems from the fact that
there's a sense that like justice isn't
being done um and you know that sort of
like
plays out in weird ways like i don't
know if you'd call shaming the guy in
costco
uh like a problem of justice but at the
same time i just want to punch that guy
so much
uh not really just metaphorically i
don't advocate violence
uh yeah it's so weird and then the last
thing i'll say is there is an
interesting
concept from the philosopher hannah rent
who talks about
the distinction between public and
private and she kind of warns about
like the private sphere is this very
important sphere
that is like uh taken out of the public
eye
it is kind of like uh not scrutinized
but uh basically when you break down
that barrier and start scrutinizing
people it's like this sort of
never-ending process that we saw
uh like in the french revolution where
all sudden like everyone becomes a
hypocrite
um and just like lots of bad
bad things can happen and i like i don't
know if hannah rent's universally right
in that sense but
i think it is an interesting thought so
i wonder
oh go ahead i do want to make a
distinction though like i have no
problem with people shaming like the
central park karen
yeah or the costco guy this is just like
if i'm walking across the street and i
happen to like
drop my freshly baked cake
and someone films that and puts it
online it's like just pour it on your
face
that's yeah let's make it viral let's
blur out your face well you can blur on
my face but like people aren't doing
that and so i don't understand like
like why why don't we just like respect
people and think like maybe i don't want
everybody to see i
dropped my cake i mean i'm the type of
person that wouldn't really care
but other people focusing on like the
wrong type of privacy though because
i don't know like i don't really care
about being filmed i care about the fact
that like
corporations and governments are
accessing our data constantly i'll be
that guy
and i just think and i think it's
telling i'm just i'll say this
um the person who did that threat is a
person that's ex-military worked in the
army and worked in intelligence so we're
talking about someone who
literally worked for the military which
does oh there's so many examples of
illegal surveillance done by the
military which have led to literally
ruining people's lives
or killing them with drones so i think
like
i don't know i just think it's kind of a
distraction that and especially the
the fact that the person who did that
thread which like articulated great
points but there i just see some
hypocrisy there
and if you're going to give me the
option to and this isn't a dichotomy
anyone's set up but i just think this
could be a distraction
from all of the privacy that we already
have lost
but maybe i'm being too extreme i'm
often accused of being extreme
i i think to your point about is this
the wrong
like is this a distraction i mean uh
ring like
there are several ring cameras uh that
the the sort of doorbell cameras i think
amazon owns them
uh and i pass by them as i'm getting
bagels and
doing my daily thing and uh
amazon owns that data and will sell it
including to like law enforcement
agencies uh
or i don't know if it's specifically
they've been implicated in selling that
specific data but amazon does like
contract and sell data to law
enforcement agencies
and uh you know also probably selling it
to make some like
creepy facial recognition app and yeah
like that's probably scarier
uh but again if you're going to share
someone doing something stupid i really
think the solution is just to blur out
their face
unless they're doing something dangerous
stupid like central park karen
i feel like can we all agree on that
agreed
wait so what do you think sorby if
someone if someone did a video okay so
you're you drop the cake
they blur your face so all they see is a
human body drop a cake
are you pissed are you okay with it i'm
fine
okay so if you see serbia dropping a
cake which she wouldn't
now but yeah who drops a cake yeah
cakes are important you care about them
um
this one contest any other thoughts on
this one and also too this is another
call if anyone does have
questions for us in the chat about this
or other things you can let us know
alec did you find anything i feel like
you're the one of us yeah i'm i'm gonna
teach you right now
give me one second i'm so distracted i
had to turn it off yeah i'll admit this
to everyone this is the first time that
serbia and myself have tried to keep up
with the chat it's it's very hard and
i'm very impressed that alec is able to
do this
oh yeah it's uh it's an acquired skill i
i've started doing this like i've always
responded to people in the the chat
occasionally
not all the time very distracting but
uh i don't know something to do with unm
unmedicated adhd i don't know
but uh uh here's
here's a specific uh comment from
benjamin who says uh animo anonymity
also allows for toxicity
look at driving or the internet is that
a good reason to remove some of that
privacy
i think that's interesting and again to
like
central park here like the sort of
anonymity of calling the cops on a
stranger
uh in the middle of a park where there
are no witnesses
like you can be a pretty big dick um
i kind of related to benjamin's comment
i also wonder
you know there are privacy protections
in the u.s
kind of surrounding around like oh like
what can police
like what level of privacy can the
police uh
violate you know to sort of apprehend
you for a crime
well you know when it comes to like
searching your house they need a warrant
or can they search like outside
in your trash can can they do this or
that can they wiretap you
um and i don't know obviously
in public there is no restriction on
like what level of sort of citizen
surveillance can happen
um and you know citizens are not like a
professional government force but it is
i think kind of interesting
should we move on cool let's move on um
we did have a kantian in the chat i
think james said film others the way you
want to be filmed the categorical
imperative he didn't say this part
it's like the categorical imperative of
public filming so i like that if you're
wondering what to do
would you want to be filmed in the way
that you're filming that person
yeah great question um okay so we now
turn to our resident
teen culture correspondent alec who's
going to talk to us
about tick tock well hello fellow kids
uh
related to privacy we're being thematic
here i want to talk about tick tock
there's been a lot in the news about
i believe one article called it
surveillance scheme thinly veiled as a
social media
site there is uh i was reading a seattle
times article
uh about it and here's a quote from
there privacy concerns have been the
most viral
aspect of the popular short video social
network in the last week on july 7
secretary of state mike pompeo said the
u.s was considering banning tick-tock
and warned it puts your private
information in the hands of the chinese
communist party
on july 10th the democratic national
committee cautioned staffers about using
it
the same day amazon also told employees
to stop using tiktok
the tick tock app on work phones but
later said that order
was sent in air weird how that can
accidentally happen uh
amazon ceo jeff bezos uh oh sorry that
was a disclaimer about him owning
washington post
anyway um tick-tock is owned by bite
dance which is a a
company based in china um
sort of surrounding this uh ninja the
famous twitch streamer who plays
fortnite said he was tweeted that he was
deleting the app
india banned it over privacy concerns as
well along with a bunch of other sort of
chinese-owned apps
as far as the data they are collecting
uh from this article it grabs what
videos you watch how long you watch them
but also your private messages
uh according to the u.s privacy policy
it says it gathers location data and the
type of device you're using
um but also there was a little bit of a
kerfuffle in that it was
on your phone looking at what you were
storing in your clipboard so if you've
ever sort of copied a message or a url
or something it was accessing that
according to tick tock it was a weird
anti-spam measure i don't know
if you're copying and pasting lots of
shady links maybe they can tell if
you're a spammer
i don't know if we should believe that
but that's what they said
um but also you know just here's what
tick tock says
um this is also a quote from the article
tick tock said the chinese government
has never asked for its user data and
that it would refuse such a request
ticktock says a security team is led out
of the us by an executive who has
decades of industry and u.s law
enforcement experience
how well could actually resist an order
is a separate question
um i have more to say but what are your
initial thoughts
i don't use tik tok but a friend of mine
is an avid tick tock watcher so she'll
send me
links to the videos so i open it up in
my like a ui
the ui version yeah um
uh i don't know i would not use
anything like that that would take my
data
in that way and i have very strong
feelings about china and surveillance
and so i i like the whole thing freaks
me do you use facebook
i do not okay so i can't i can't i can't
hypocrite shame you
uh what about instagram no
oh well i have a like an instagram that
i i never post on it
i just follow my friends they know they
know a lot about
you based on your friend well that's
fair i'm not gonna give you [ __ ]
uh really what do you think oh and i use
whatsapp too
well so i think and i know serbia
implies i feel like you know about this
i don't know a lot about
uh chinese data surveillance in general
but yeah i guess my thought with all
this is sort of like
if we're not going to use tick-tock we
probably shouldn't use everything else
because don't i think we have pretty
clear evidence that and you know i'm not
good because i do still have a facebook
account and i truly hate myself for
still having one
um and then instagram owned by facebook
so same thing
uh yeah i just worry like it's sometimes
you know what it feels like to me it
just feels like
it's it's we can either get off
everything or just stay on
because like what's the point i guess
and i don't use tick tock
um but yeah i just wonder if it's really
ever the point of getting off one thing
but maybe and i would love it if one of
you teach me about this
is there like a difference or is it
worse that tick tock
a company based in china is gathering
information versus a company based in
like silicon valley getting my
information
yeah so i think that's what's kind of
interesting because there's uh some
american laws based around foreign
investment in companies and
essentially if there's a national
security threat
the government can force the foreign
company to divest and so a famous
example there was a chinese company that
owned a stake in grinder uh the gay
dating app
and basically i think was congress
decided that this is a huge
uh national security threat like if uh
you know someone in the military
is on grindr who is maybe you know in
the closet or something
they could blackmail that the chinese
government could blackmail that person
if they acquired that data
um and so you know i get that kind of
stuff but as far as
um tick tock you know
is there i guess a unique threat uh that
they're gonna get blackmailed more than
they get blackmailed by
even the their own government i mean i i
can't cite any recent examples but the
fbi has
famously tried to blackmail people like
martin luther king jr
um and so
you know i'm not going to say america
has its problems
i'm not going to try to do apples to
apples on china because they've got
a very specific set of problems uh
but when it comes to them sort of like
tracking our data in the videos we watch
you know
like if we sort of bracket out the
blackmail maybe what's in our private
messages which i can't imagine is uh
you know a ton if you're a 14 year old
but maybe there is
um yeah they're just doing all the [ __ ]
that
facebook already does in fact this
article even says that facebook collects
way more data and facebook famously
collected data about people who didn't
even
have accounts based on what your friends
were doing um and then that data gets
sold to
sort of data collection companies and
then uh
whether you're an advertising agency or
the us government or the chinese
government or any other government you
could buy that data
so you know even if the government's not
wiretapping you they can certainly buy a
lot of information about you and i think
there's been a lot of like implications
about this
um so it seems again to your point like
i don't want to say it's a full-blown
distraction i think you know
uh we should be wary of this kind of
stuff but at the same time
uh i just want us to in the same breath
be like this is bad and scary but also
super bad and scary is like everything
facebook is doing
i think it's a little different i mean i
think there's one clear what there's one
distinction to make in that
if the chinese government is taking data
he could die
maybe in china if they find something
they can like
oh yeah but also uh there was something
about
i don't know like there's a weird wall
between
tic toc like i don't know if tiktok is
the same in china i think it's mostly an
international app
um there was something in the article
about there being a difference between
like
u.s tic-tac but yeah but you're talking
about like a person in china using
tik-tok
right like in terms of data collection
like oh sure facebook collects data
you probably you may not die here but if
if you're a chinese citizen in china and
they find
like messages or whatever videos that
you're watching
you could die that's horrifying yeah
i would hope the people doing that would
be on like signal or something instead
of
saying like i hate the chinese
government
um but yeah that's bad i'm not i don't
mean to belittle that
yeah so i guess if you're in china
please be smart and do your subversive
thing
on a safe mechanism and if you're in
in the united states or europe please
keep making funny subversive tick tocks
that i can watch
um all right uh
anything else to add
no no it's always i mean this is like
the depression show because all these
topics are making me so sad not in a bad
way but just like
i just like where are we going because
there's just no end in sight with this
everyone's gonna have all of our data
and sometimes i just stop caring because
i'm like why even fight it
why fight having some corporation know
everything about me i might as well just
send them a docket with all my
information anyways
yeah sorry that's a little grim um any
did we find any questions
uh well uh someone named jay just said
thank goodness i have no friends
uh what a great sentiment
damn dude yeah uh we've got a lot of
cool voicemails and uh let's get to
email so let's get into that
uh our wonderful producer joy can you
play
the first voicemail hey livecrack this
is jason i'm calling in about the most
recent episode of culture binge
uh specifically the separating the
artist from the art topic
this is a topic that i just find
genuinely interesting
and has been very relevant the last few
years and i just try and talk to as many
people as i can about it because
it seems that really no one agrees fully
and there's lots of different
perspectives and obviously
lots of nuance you guys touched on how
there's really no like
good rule of thumb to judge
a person or a piece of art by
um but one point that i just wanted to
bring up that uh no one mentioned on the
show
uh which i think is especially relevant
to movies less so maybe
novels or music or something like that
but with movies
a lot more people than just one actor
one director etc work on it
so if you decide that
you are complicit in supporting some
nefarious criminal activity by watching
a movie that's directed by someone with
a shitty past
uh you also are kind of throwing a bunch
of other people onto the bus who had
no part in that um i think a really good
example
is the usual suspects which uh for many
years was just revered as like one of
the great crime movies
but it was directed by brian singer and
the starring kevin spacey
who both have similar allegations of
sexual assault
and that obviously sucks
but i still really love that movie and a
big part of it is
you know i love christopher macquarie
who wrote the movie you don't have to
direct a bunch of great stuff like the
mission impossible
uh movies of late and so i do think that
it's important to keep that in mind keep
the context in mind for what these
people have done
but you also don't want to then screw
over the writer
or the producer or the coast guards or
just the technical people
who are you know not getting any
recognition
by them pirating the movie or boycotting
it or whatever that that's just my two
cents on it i loved your discussion and
i can't wait to hear
further episodes thanks that was really
great
yeah i also we're doing a a script that
kind of touches on this but
i think we often view important things
as done by like a single person
and not like the countless people behind
them like we talk about
napoleon being this mastermind and not
like the countless soldiers and generals
and colonels and all that stuff
um and yeah like a movie
is partly great because of the director
the writer and
you know certain actors um but also
you know the set designers and the
costume designers and
all the designers and the the camera
people and so
yeah i think there's like a real danger
of
you know like if the mic if you if
every thing on a movie was great except
the guy who
uh held the boom was like an [ __ ]
like would we would we
freak out in the same way as you know if
there's an ensemble cast with kevin
spacey
um so i think that's a really good
perspective
yeah it makes me think of restaurants
because it's sort of this thing where
if there's a scandal where we find out
like the head chef or owner of replace
is a piece of [ __ ]
in general the like fancy chef is rarely
there it's a bunch of line cooks and
servers
and dishwashers and food runners doing
everything and they could all be
the best people ever so do i want to
like not
you know support them and yeah for me
this is like it just comes down like a
personal
sense then right because i think there's
some people who can watch usual suspects
and be like this is a good movie
even if the director and one of the
stars are horrible
and maybe for some people it just kills
the vibe to see kevin spacey on screen
but yeah i definitely think that makes
sense that we shouldn't just like
unequivocally cancel artistic projects
that involve
hundreds if not thousands of humans
being involved with them we also
uh i don't think we have time to play
the full the voicemail but we got a
voicemail from someone named t
who was like it's all it feels a little
different when you're like sort of
personally
attacked like you know uh
if you're black and a certain director
says something incredibly racist there's
something maybe a little more personal
about that
uh it was a really i definitely
understand that sentiment and i don't
want to speak for
anyone else but myself but mel gibson is
a horrible anti-semite i
really want to watch the original mad
max and i'm sorry i'm sorry if that
makes me a bad person
wow um and i want to watch
the beaver the mel gibson film where
he's a grieving father that wears a
puppet on his hand that he uses to
communicate his feelings because he
can't do it
through words oh i don't think that's a
real movie or i just made that up sorry
thanks for
that mel gibson is that of an actor so i
don't really care
yeah i just want to watch mad max
because we did a video and it seems so
good
uh anyway um we have one more voicemail
but
how can people leave us a voicemail
michael oh so many ways
um one find me on the street i'll write
it down i'll communicate it too
um email culture wisecrack.co
as always no m culture wisecrack.co or
call us
on the phone 213-534-8807 that's
213-534-8807
we love hearing from you um and just so
you know if we don't get to it on the
show it's just because we talk too much
we read all of these we listen to all of
them
and we appreciate the hell out of it so
uh please do get in touch
culture binge at wisecrack yeah
no yeah it's called your binge watch
nobody listen to me whoever's editing
this
why do i have this i don't know if it's
that culture
anyway we got one more voicemail it's a
good one can you play that joy total
failure hi this is golden vision long
time listener first time caller
and i like the topic of reality tv that
you were getting on
there's a lot of trash out there but i
like that you were talking about
real world nyc because it was tackling
those issues of race so
i have a question flash a little game
for you guys to play
uh if you each could create your own
reality tv show to highlight an issue
or to perhaps help people shut their
brain off whichever you can choose
what kind of reality show would you
pitch thanks bye-bye
it's a fun question i really want to do
a reality show i don't even know that
much about it but about people who do
mukbang
that's not a joke i've thought about
this often before uh
am i the co-host you could be
i only watch it if serbia's the co-host
in case you care yeah
um i also there's documentaries about
this
and i sorry for bringing it up again the
college debate world is [ __ ] nuts
and a reality show about all those
[ __ ]
i love them all dearly but we all kind
of suck anyway
what about you guys would like to do
something that's like a creative
thing like the bake like the great
british great british bake off
but something where it's like like
calligraphy or like some of these like
japanese
um arts like uh what is it called
hibana i think like the flower
arrangement or maybe like calligraphy or
there's one about like wrapping presents
with a cloth um i think that could be
kind of cool or maybe like storytelling
like you give somebody a prompt and they
have to create like a
like a story on the spot could be cool
or
maybe like a watercolor kind of thing
something that's like fun and relaxing
oh it's supposed to be about an issue
right not just a reaction
oh yeah what about you michael okay the
show is called the beat my crew
it's a reality competition show where
you put together a crew of five friends
now there's categories right you might
have
the person who's like really smart the
person who's good with technical skills
maybe someone who's good
who's like really funny and someone
who's athletic and in your wild card
you compete in a series of competitions
and we determine who
america's ultimate crew is um
that's that's my what what are they
competing in just anything so you'd have
different stuff so like there could be
maybe like one thing you could have a
challenge that's like uh
trivia based so maybe we do like a
trivia thing and we see which crew has
brains maybe another one is
last minute we're like three-course meal
10 guests
can your crew throw a dinner party on
short notice and maybe there's another
one where it's like here's two big logs
your crew needs to get these over this
fence whether with brawn or with
with your mind by building a pulley
system so that we're really
trying to find a group of friends that
have all of the necessary skills
separately but when they come together
are an unstoppable force
could you do like you have 48 hours to
prepare a case against
maxwell is that could that be part of it
i i would think that would be
kind of like one of the like the final
level and i would hope that we would
work with the justice system
to to make that actual so it would
actually
the at the end of this show is maxwell
on trial
and then could other now i'm just
talking thinking about ryan's game show
which is amazing everyone should watch
but like
do my taxes or um
yeah then we can i guess we're not going
to exploit people though because it's
about positivity and
the main point of the show is we are
promoting the power of friendship
and the importance of all types of
diversity in your friend groups because
you're more powerful
when you unite with those that are not
like you because if everyone's like you
you're not going to make it past the
first week
yeah i i would i would actually watch
that especially
if they had to do some more absurd
things uh
anyway we have a couple emails uh
we don't have a time for a ton but this
first one and just a reminder it's
culture binge at wisecrack.co if you
want to email us
culture binge if anyone emails culture
at wisecrack
you're in serious trouble do not put
pertinent information in there and i'm
sorry that i'm an idiot the chinese
government will intercept it uh here's
an email from dan
maybe you came across it already but in
the uh sorry hey culture binge crew and
especially michael maybe you came across
it already
but in the uk we have two long-running
dating shows that you may be interested
to check out
first dates the first one is a really
straightforward blind
blind date type setup the whole show is
in the same restaurant in london
and the participants cover the bases of
all kinds of orientations ages and
backgrounds
the show does the matchmaking although
sometimes it seems like the pairing is
made for entertainment value
more than genuine connection this is
always clearly done without bad
intentions for example it may be a
humbling experience for one
or both of the people honestly some of
the best cases of the show
are the super old people i would watch
shows about old people dating
even though it's gross um the second
show sorry i'm sorry
i i'm i'm a monster um the second is a
show called the undateables that follows
people with different kinds of
disabilities or differences as they
navigate the dating world it is so
damn wholesome that i often come home
just to find my
housemate watching it while weeping
gently into her protein shake
she's on a health care anyway i hope you
get some enjoyment and feels
from these love what you do dan what
great recommendations
great um i watched that show and i lived
in the uk i was obsessed with it and i
think uk reality tv is better in general
than american reality tv
i wanna i'm gonna download a vpn so i
can get back
and watch some british shows again great
wrecks uh and you're you saw first dates
is what you're saying
yes yes yes first dates is very
incredible all right
next one's an email from teo hey culture
bingers teo here writing from
brazil uh i really agree with alec about
how commuting has destroyed our lives
i'm an architect and an urbanist and
i've studied a lot of the issues like
that so i could go on and on about city
planning and how it is [ __ ] up
but i think nothing explains it better
than my personal experience i come from
sao paulo
a metro a metropolis with over 20
million inhabitants where commuting can
literally take up to three
or more hours if you live far away from
the city center i live in a reasonably
central area and would take about one to
one and a half hours commuting to the
university every morning
and evening when i was studying standing
the bus all the way of course
and basically took that as normal i
would wake up super early get to uni
already tired and when it may when it
when i made it home at 8 pm i would be
destroyed
the same for all my friends then i moved
to munich germany
since munich is a city with about only
about 1.5 million inhabitants
and has a great transport system even
living quite far from the
city center i would be at work or back
home in less than 20 minutes
with what really is a life changer the
main difference is that if you are done
with work at about 5 p.m
germans rarely work past that and know
you can be home at 5 20 you feel much
more free to engage in other activities
like hanging out with friends
going to movies or even to a park after
work on a weekday this not only makes
for more pleasant days but also takes a
lot of the pressures from the weekends
that most germans use to relax and
attend to home related issues in sao
paulo
what happens is the opposite if you and
all your friends get home late and tired
every day and i have to wake up early in
the morning
that puts a lot of social pressure on
the weekends quote if we don't hang out
now
we will have to wait a whole other week
this leaves no space for the rest and
making the whole work week just a
dragged out waiting period small changes
and commute time can really take the joy
of working
i think that is in itself a major issue
that said i still
love to live in sao paulo maybe that's
because i'm a bit of a junkie for big
metropolitan areas haha
keep up the great work teo thanks to
do you remember when you used to get
back from work and you'd go see friends
yeah well now i get on zoom calls with
them but now i'm zoomed out
yeah i have to zoom the zoom all server
you still zoom in
i have zoom all day for work so i'm not
okay so you're zoomed out
yeah wow well that was great and i agree
on on the fact that
we all agree with that like the
commuting ruins everything so i i
um i will say a recent development my
life not that i've ever commuted but my
my partner who doesn't now after work it
used to be
i'm so [ __ ] tired i don't want to
leave the house now it's let's go on a
walk and you know we're
fitting in like mile mile and a half
walk every day
wow we'll see yeah that's lovely um are
there any more emails or calls one quick
one
great it's a recommendation for serbie i
know sir we talked about our love for
spelling bees i want to recommend the
netflix documentary spelling dream
great use of half an hour great use of
an hour and a half
from sam so sam i saw your email come
through
and i actually added it to my watch list
and i plan to do that this week when i
take two weeks off of work
nice hell yes wow so we'll remind you
once again recommend more stuff
prioritize serbia of course because
she's the best of us um but then if you
have trash recommendations alec
and myself will eat them up like the
culture rats that we are and you can
send them to
culture binge at wisecrack.com and call
us at 213-534-8807
i also just want to say hi to generic
username who asked me to
so oh what up generic username hi
generic username
okay so let's say people have a culture
recommendation and they think i can't i
can't write an email right now
gmail kicked me out i do have a twitter
account though
how could i get in touch with alec or
serbi
and tell them to watch a dutch dating
show
that involves sea creatures
i'm oh i didn't mean to do that i just
picked a random country and it happened
to be that one
never mind everyone this is a dating
show takes place in in
austria and it's people who date by
making uh pastries
and it's called let's let's cake it um
so how could they serve if someone
wanted to tell you about that show how
could they let you know immediately via
the powers of social media
tweet me at siri patel 22
you heard her tweeter alex and i'm in
question i'm on twitter at wisecrack
alec alec
great um and if you want to tweet at me
and and tell me that i don't care about
basketball the way i said i do and then
i'm a fake uh
at michael o burns um no michael jordan
scottie pippen
larry bird okay um that is all for this
time we are going to be back in two
weeks thank you so much for everyone who
hung out in the chat and asked questions
it's a new thing we're trying sorry if
it felt sloppy that's our fault not
yours
and we'll see you in two weeks bye
[Music]
everyone
[Music]
you